gang let's talk about that middle class
famous tour baby coming to a town near
you the hottest thing on the road right
now we've been zipping all over the
country and we're coming to a town near
you kippy straighten them out first of
all we got a second show out in chicago
sold the first one out yes we did zany's
still some tickets left for the late
show then we're over there in rosemont
tickets are moving for that so get them
goddamn
then we're also going to be in
pittsburgh buffalo and detroit get them
now before they're gone yeah stand up
show we play ayg with the crowd you've
seen the clips what are we doing come
see us bring the homies bring the bozos
bring the squad do it welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage hey it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they grow up to be
classy yeah or if they're just a big old
piece of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day down here in aunt toddy's
basement she's outside in the backyard
getting a little sun okay yeah
bottomless oh which is a strange choice
no and she could use a trim i could tell
you that much get that michael who's
coming at you from across the table
unamused this week i failed them yet
again it was a family episode yeah just
got back from tejas yeah we're hanging
out uh-huh we're back here at tutti's
sure are you're looking good you got a
new jackie thanks down there in texas
feeling pretty good ladies and gentlemen
my best pal the guy that forehead
magazine called number one in their book
kevin james ryan did you just tell me
i'm feeling good hey
this is kj if he's feeling good what's
up everybody thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on itunes ball video available
youtube and as you know those numbers
are true
uh and then obviously
www.patreon.com garbage come on i mean
aside from the bonus episodes you get
every week aside from the ayg bonus
aside from the [ __ ] hard feelings
aside from the monthly live streams i
mean we just booked disney taking a big
man down to disney for the first time
that video is going to be up there we
got the ten thousand dollar on black
spin and ac
coming pretty [ __ ] soon by the way
scheduling that
uh we got just bonus videos from the
shore cribs car video everything check
it the [ __ ] out gang but that hard
feelings that's the money maker man
that's what people tune in for
up and down you're smoking cigarettes
you're watching it what's going to
happen is it going to get fatter is he
going to get skinnier oh fat court by
the way we're in the middle of [ __ ]
fat court season two
this time i put the system on trial
how about a nice quick shot sizzler on
trial
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
he's got the midas touch he's got long
flowing
locks of hair and a beard
and a [ __ ] like a big old suzy
it's t-boned mcmuffin i saw that thing
poking out of the underwear down at the
airbnb god damn the rumors are true a
little anteater popping out my
reputation precedes me gentlemen t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen got damaged show
them some respect ebay what's up dudes
my mom listens to the show uh she knows
she's the one who gave it to you
dude speaking of that ten thousand
dollar bet yeah i've met aka one akash
singh's wife yeah and who's doubling it
by the way and watch his match not to
misses what
his wife's not doubling he's doubling it
correct akash is doubling it and i
watched him tell her that for the first
time 20 seconds after meeting me
i am her least favorite person on earth
that is no bueno
yes 20k we're throwing down yikes
it's either gonna be a great night
or a really bad year sure
it's gonna be one of the other but we're
doing it we're doing it we're new money
we're doing it we're getting mistakes or
no more health insurance one of the
other holy's gonna walk out of the
bellagio straight into the citizen one
bank looking for a loan now if we lose
i'm gonna go outside
shoot myself have somebody
have somebody hit me in the head with a
baseball bat and i'm gonna deny the
whole thing and actually i don't know
what you guys are talking about that's
another one
that's another guy's 410 pounds at the
blackjack table probably the same guy's
smoking over in l.a
anywho gang it's a family episode it's
just us we're back we want to have a
nice quiet evening just us and the bozos
and the homies sure hanging out um
i might have asked you this before i'm
listening but i've been dealing with it
a little bit more lately
um
[Music]
watch your belly button
routine
what do you have one
no
i treat my belly button like i treat my
feet grab it it cleans itself they're
self-cleaning you don't scrub your feet
no
you don't wash your feet now
wow that's weird i can't even reach my
feet and i use my brush
same thing i do with my grundle
let's scrub it all out that poor brush
that's the dude the best the best part
of that that brush's day is your feet
that's bad news i'll even hang it in the
shower uh oh no it's [ __ ] day
it's always that's all day
um do
uh yeah no clean it
it cleans itself
water gets in there i mean
i i think our belly buttons live very
differently we talked about this you
smelled my belly button on an episode
yeah it was horrific yeah thank you
don't don't get me wrong mine will get
ripe if i'm like if it's sweaty or
whatever it gets cheesy yeah well it's
the difference between a kiddie pool on
kippy and an olympic-sized swimming pool
there's not a whole bunch that can go on
a trench got a bunch of kids hanging out
there like they're at the quarry yeah
getting trench foot and [ __ ] i got two
subs down there
wrecked on the bottom on the floor
that's coral reef growing in that bad
boy
they go to your belly button to sink
ships to manufacture coral reefs a
couple of subway cars in there too tiger
shark breeding ground down there giant
squid megalodon fighting in there too
well the reason i asked is because i
have a nice little routine now when i
get out of the shower okay i take it you
get out you do it huh i figured that'd
be a pre
that seems like shaving to me if you
have a routine no i just i i get out of
the shower
i literally a chill just ran through my
spine dude i swear to god
i get out of the shower uh-huh okay
which i started doing your thing by the
way what's my thing bye don't be
stealing my thing don't th the wiping
yourself off with your hand before you
actually get out yeah like a civilized
human never did it before a lot of water
does come off oh it all comes off listen
this is what you look like shamwow
it's like a squeegee you got to take
care of the head first that's where most
of the moisture is held
your hair it's like cutting a sneaker
you gotta [ __ ] if you dry your hair
first and then work your way down you do
a
slurp a couple of these it's like it's
like you're telling them to steal home
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
uh you do a couple of them down to the
you know whatever yeah try all the what
you know i do a couple of cups of water
come off you then i get out and i do my
ears i do my ears every day q-tips
i use one q-tip one side one side throw
that out and then i get another q-tip
put it in alcohol and i just go in there
and
what do we do
what kind of alcohol are we talking
captain
jack what are we doing
you use rubbing alcohol in your belly
button every day yeah why is that bad it
seems like overkill no it does i want to
keep it clean i'm trying to take care of
myself i mean i was also not an open
wound is it
it bleeds sometimes
is that bad it ain't good police in
there with gunpowder cauterizing his
belly button he's got a belt in his
mouth
do it doc do it yeah what's with this
civil war [ __ ] healthcare you got
going on everything clean out my belly
button like a gentleman so it doesn't
smell anymore i'm trying to improve
myself
i also struck oil down there too
a couple of derrick scouts like the
clampetts um
that's i mean i know i'm just shocked
that you're cleaning your belly button
with alcohol i'm good for good on you if
it helps the problem i clean my belly
button with alcohol and i floss those
are the two things i'm really good at
everything else i really gotta pick up
in life yeah the whole situation those
who seem like you know
very minor details when it comes to your
your health and happiness is flossing
and
alcohol in the belly button sure well
toby and i were talking in the in the
vehicle on our way on our way over i
just uh i just cut the lawn down there
your pubes did you cleaned it up did you
do it
she's a good woman
tell you that
couples do that kind of [ __ ] for each
other yeah weirdos
i'm not shaving me my wife don't shave
each other really what
that's crazy what are you guys barbers
it's like going to the vet or something
yeah trim me up
because here's my problem
can i get real for a second no no man
between the belly button
and your weird sexual proclivities i'm
not sexual proclivities though i do have
them ladies gentlemen if you ever get
the opportunity to throw h-foley under
the bus you gotta give it a whirl it's a
good time
told you that confidence you piece of
[ __ ]
you ride in the back from that one
at least tell me use the lawnmower 4.0
of course i did i'm not a [ __ ] i
don't know if that's this week maybe we
bleep it
[Laughter]
just says naroco
um
well here's my sitch he's national
leading brand
here's my sick what
i i can pick up it's probably not easy
for you no though yeah of course i mean
that's a given it's not easy and my
brush won't do it um nothing on that all
right um
but the uh
things build up down there
like what it's it's just it's among the
cheese it's an odd yet appealing aroma
i believe among the cheese i believe
it's a little urine
probably some semen in the hair in the
hair
because when you put it back
what when you tinkle and then you put it
back there's still a dribble or two it
gets in the hair and wait where pubes
smell weird
they don't smell great well not now now
they do put it back
yeah it sounds like it's detachable like
it's a cat stick
what do you don't think about corkscrews
or something i'm out that's why yeah
that's why i don't do cats
i'd never give me a red rocket something
i know and trust you know dude i
remember staring at my dog's dick for
like
for like two weeks when i was a kid
that's the name of your memoir
staring at mine i understand at that
thing being like what the [ __ ] is that
that's one of the most phallous things
in nature is the dick of a dog
for something so cute and adorable
he really got shafted on coming out of
the assembly line on that one
anyway okay it yeah it gets i don't know
it gets like a like a uriny smell
because when i put my my my wee wee back
how long are your pubes they were bad
that's what i'm saying like what studio
54.
like give me like they were like draft
dodger
rock and roll bass player
that's what we're talking here
yeah like toby's
i keep my [ __ ] tight son there was a
couple of them that outstretched the uh
the unit itself still dinky
your old tinky winky
that little lincoln lock
the little guy
butt all scrubbed out cleaned that all
up use my brush scrubbed that clean
fresh as a whistle
plus i started using
um we have to talk about this
prior to the recording you can't just
throw this stuff out at me it's no good
it's not so i'm not saying it's bad it's
just a lot to take in you have to
realize that we're not all walking
around as you so what's normal for you
might be a little startling to those
around you
but i'm sure i know the big guys out
there know what i'm talking about i'm
the point is i'm i'm tackling it head-on
i'm going straight at it tightening
everything up
i use a little uh not vagina
i mean what's the feminine hygiene spray
what
you know what i'm talking about
no yeah it's i think it is vagisil they
use you know they spray it down there to
keep everything dry summer's eve
something like that
i used that yesterday normally i use
gold bond spray after i get everything
all cleaned up i do my hair dryer how
often are you doing this why are we
talking about this
the trim i do as needed but the
scrubbing doesn't sound like you do it
as needed when i realize oh [ __ ] yeah
that's not as sweet it smells
it's like a dead body in an old
apartment you got smelly pubes your ball
sack i get a workout i really have a
long day at the factory a long day
running around i get that i really have
to scrub but your pubes smell mm-hmm
just get caught i'm sure your pubes
smell right now
if you scratch out of the shower in an
hour if you scratched your pubes and
smelled it there would be a little bit
maybe a little bleach a little something
my pubes don't i dude i would a hint of
raspberry something i would be on my
pubes notes of vanilla just got out of
the shower are your pubes long
uh right now i don't think so i keep it
pretty tight when you when you when you
trim down do you go all the way i get a
little wacky down there uh
it depends
logo sometimes you go you know it
depends i try to keep an even you know
try to keep it fair and balanced down
there on the left and the right you know
i call balls and strikes this is not
urine by the way
it's not my urine
[Laughter]
i'm not a
weirdo um
yeah i use you know uh i kind of just
give it a quick once-over i go shorter
than i intend to when i start out put it
that way you know what i mean i should
go for like a four or whatever i don't
know i go long i go short i mean
okay i really you know keep it high and
tight down there yeah i used to use a
blade and cream for a long time that's
the most insane thing i've ever heard in
my life oh is it
drinks his own urine and has smelly
pubes i am not drinking my own urine
it's gatorade it's uh red sugar-free red
bull with water
diluted a little bit can't have the
caffeine vanilla something to keep me
going it all goes in the same place
though you know that what's that
you're still consuming the same amount
of caffeine i understand okay so then
why did you just lie a second ago
i don't know
old habits die hard i guess man we are
descending into the ville of foley
i can't believe a blade and cream i
don't do it no more straight razor yeah
like a bick no straight razor no i'm not
an old [ __ ] barber
in your bathroom with a clown mask on
[Laughter]
yanking my wing out getting the getting
the sideburns yeah you got to pull it
out
that's what i do i pull it out while
she's i get it hard before i do it are
you kidding me
well that would make it easier of course
plus it shows you what the performance
is going to look like not dresser sure
yeah yeah cause sometimes you go it and
then you know it's time to perform and
you realize you got a bad do going
you know it looks like you're joining
the army or something
put a hat on that kid jesus christ
yeah you got to go dark for a couple of
days
shut it down
shut down production i'm closing the
studio
[Laughter]
tell me insurance didn't come through or
something i don't know can't find a grip
we're out for a little while yeah
yeah
okay
but yeah i was a blading cream for a
long time wild
gets you real smooth down there i know
but doesn't eggs yeah it cuts myself
like eggs
it's a weird comparison this is your
pelvis
and it's as smooth as that yeah
no but when it grows back then you get a
lot of ingrown hairs and like it really
itches as is coming through
maybe i haven't done it in forever
but yeah maybe settle them down you
would do it in the shower i would do it
in the shower and then that's when
you're like oh i've gone too far you
know what i mean
yeah i would go in for a little trim
around like you know the thighs are you
know tighten it up tighten the ship up
they see you know you're knuckle deep
there's a couple of dead bodies and i'm
digging in the cellar
yeah it's real uh real real
it escalates quickly yeah okay
but i've shaved my butthole before you
ever shave your butthole i'll get in the
gooch
you get in the gooch yeah see that's a
little bit that's a dangerous area i
also use this i use the same trimmer on
my face and all my balls
yeah
and you're sitting there judging me
yeah but clean
toby how do you feel about that super
gross super gross it is what it is
what kind of equipment do you use
use the lumbar 1.0 no uh i'll use the
lomo for that you don't use that on you
use the lawnmower on your face sometimes
really my neck okay yeah okay i'll trim
i'll tighten it up with the lawnmower
not just for balls no
it's not
this is like ayg after dark what are we
doing here there's a family program your
mothers listen yeah she is
she does she knows she used to do it for
me before when i was in high school
[Laughter]
i get down here i got to trim my pews my
i got prom in an hour let's go
tighten them up a little bit
not on oven mitts and bush trimmers
she got goggles
get the big extension cord
the outdoor one the orange one terry
hearing anywho
we got a goddamn family episode going on
right now yes we do where we answer your
questions from what was our website
again patreon.com
signed up by jack conte and sam yam guys
when you sign up for patreon we will
answer your question on air uh it's just
the best way to do it the patreons get
the first great eating yeah i mean we
know you know i'm telling him i know you
know i know i know you know that i know
that you know
that i know
sure how much was that jacket too much
200 no
more less
thanks for foley in this game 150 149 45
something like that all right i was
drunk when they got me um it was one of
those things like the the extra large
was too big the medium was too small and
he's like oh we might have one black
large one i'm like let me came down i
was just like it fit i'm like i'll take
it and then i didn't even look i swiped
the card as like achy machi can't let's
talk about helix helix helix helix kippy
you know them you love them you sleep on
one every single night i was in one this
morning yes you were so was i
gang helix let me tell you something you
don't want to be going to the mattress
store like a bozo and dealing with some
dirt ball you can go on helix you could
take the quiz you can find out how you
sleep and they can
get a mattress that matches exactly how
you like to sleep yeah what sounds easy
this quiz is probably what half hour 45
minutes two three minutes two minutes i
took it myself minute and a half if you
cheat me
if you look if you got a nosy neighbor
me and my wife took it we were matched
with the twilight uh
mattress it's fantastic we loved it we
loved it so much we even upgraded to a
king size now we're in there and we use
the promo code garbage there you go you
save a couple of bucks it's easy peasy
if you're looking for a mattress just
take the quiz or the mattress match to
you and it comes right to your door
shipped free you don't ever have to go
to the mattress store again
uh just go to helixsleep.com take the
two minutes leave quiz and they'll match
you with a customized mattress to give
you the best sleep of your life 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights free risk-free they'll even pick
it up if you don't love it but i'm
telling you you got the kj stamp of
approval you will love it even got
financing options flexible payment plans
so a good night's sleep is not that far
away helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix leap dot com
slash garbage one more time helix
sleep.com garbage do it gang this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy as you know the most
important relationship that you have is
the one you have with yourself you ain't
lying big man which i found out the hard
way not a fan of this guy
and if you need to talk to somebody
better help can actually help you yes uh
it's easy peasy uh better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see any one camera
if you don't want to but i recommend it
you get the eye contact they pick up
it's easy see how they're living it's
much more affordable than in person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist under 48 hours which is huge
if you've ever tried to get into therapy
uh it can seem daunting and you're
calling people you're leaving messages
they're calling you back a week later
then they schedule out 14 months it's
this is easy all under 48 hours you'll
be matched with a therapist give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
all you garbage listeners get a 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
garbage do it yeah
all right let's get right into it
speaking of daily cleaning hygiene look
at that that was not planned that's how
it always works out well it wasn't the
first one i had pulled i wove it in nice
like a pro there you go then bragged
about it uh this one's from kevin james
ryan gosling love the name buddy great
yeah um
never had one red ever use dish soap in
lieu of body wash or a bar of soap
yeah we've
we've touched on this i think a little
bit
for
uh
in the summers when i was landscaping
uh-huh
you'd be around poison ivy all the time
oh yeah that you so you got a it was
palmolive
regular palm olive smells so [ __ ]
good
it's unbelievable the blue stuff or the
green the green the green the green get
that goku around the top of that nose oh
when you would run out i would rub my
fingers on that together sure that's
where the flavor smell off yeah
[Laughter]
um
we should you know we would if we the
last house of the day we'd [ __ ] strip
down into our our jean shorts or
whatever we had on and you stand at the
hose and you'd [ __ ] yeah wash off
with that it's terrible for the skin
but it dries out whatever oh my god but
i got used to it and i started using it
in the shower for a little while
i don't there's no shame in it
it's what you got to do that's what you
got to do but like
take me my average day-to-day as you
would call it sure be bopping around the
city couple of spots in the house dog
for a walk come in record whatever
nothing too strenuous you know what i
mean okay i'm not sh a whole bunch of
schmidty
but like i would just clean with water
if i didn't have soap until
like just that one time and then i would
buy soap wait what do you mean you would
take a shower without using soap
if i didn't have soap before i use like
palm olive or whatever yeah just [ __ ]
scrub the pitties unless i would use
some conditioner or champ i mean shampoo
is
that's the same same [ __ ] buddy i use
shampoo when i have soap oh me too
sometimes i just want the smell yeah you
get like a suave cool breeze yeah take
me right to give me a pina colada and
put my toes in this yeah sometimes i
just go for it she has a really good
expensive shampoo in there all that
stuff i don't touch the cold press
yeah no
uh i use bar soap as a lot of you know
still strict bar man but if i did run
out i would just water up because i'm
not like
that's
that's that's cookie talk
what's the point of death just
man all right but it's also i can't i
can't i'm not judging your lifestyle but
i can't connect to that
is that is that the thing you refer to
as rinsing off
because you use the phrase rinsing off
sometimes i jump in and just rinse off
is that what you call i always use soap
if i'm in the shower i use soap but
here's also the thing i'm not getting in
the [ __ ] shower knowingly i don't
have soap
i get in the shower i'm soaked i realize
i don't have soap i'm not gonna get out
of the shower
walk into the kitchen wet as [ __ ] got a
little hanzi you know trying to lick my
noodle or whatever and get [ __ ] palm
olive or whatever we use you walk around
the house naked at all not really no
no i'm rolling around that [ __ ]
yeah like a nude beach in
paraguay uh-uh now i'll be boxers you
know skivs and a t-shirt is typically
like what i snooze in so i'll get up
i'll make some eggies like that or
whatever
you know
but that's about it
but yeah no i i would just go like
well this is what i'm this is you're in
that situation but then also i'm in that
situation of i don't have soap i don't
have conditioner i don't have shampoo
like that
conditioner's off the table what are you
talking about nah you just need
something with a little
conditioner i'm not choose by the you're
acting like i'm telling you to do this
but you're making these decisions
conditioner what am i going to run to
the store real quick i'm in a goddamn
shower
conditioner
man this kid's like an onion i'm just
saying if i'm in a shower and there's no
soap there's no shampoo
there's just one bottle of conditioner
you're going to get out and go to the
kitchen and get palm olive
for sure that's that's crazy
you get a little lather going get the
smell get a little coconut whatever
you're cooking there's no suds with
conditioner yeah i real hey i'm
operating this is wartime what are you
talking about of course this is not
ideal no
i'd get out of the shower get some soap
that's insane to me you know what patty
did the other day what no your laundry i
disagree what you know he's not gonna
walk and get soap no you just sit here
and lie and we're just supposed to
believe it there's no way you would walk
to the kitchen and get soaked i wouldn't
i wouldn't use conditioner i know that
having been on the road with you i know
exactly what you would do what's that
you would turn the water off you'd slide
the curtain to the side and you'd yell
until someone brought it to you yeah
that's pretty good
that's what it's like on the road with
foley in an airbnb
what'd you say that's exactly what i
would know
and i'd be real pissed if nobody heeded
to my to my if nobody heard my cries
you stink on every level
that toilet paper
uh toilet paper i think my toilet paper
brought to me
oh man
my wife
uh
bought toilet paper at the bodega
because we ran out and like
you can't leave hans is still like you
don't want to leave hans outside you
know what i mean oh what like like wrap
them around like a pole or whatever
um i would do it if he's like a
full-grown dog not a puppy it's gets you
know gets scooped up too sweet but
so the only thing like in our
neighborhood to let you go in with a dog
is the bodega so she was like all right
i'll walk you just like you know what
dude this toilet paper smells like
chicken fingers french fry it smells
like it was in the deep fryer dude i
went to blow my nose with it yesterday
would you buy this at the bodega she's
like yeah how'd you know i'm like i got
falafel in my nose what do you mean
there's white sauce everywhere
oh dude it smells like dale what's with
these [ __ ] bodegas have no
ventilation the money the dollar bills
smell like grease you're like what's
going on here cranking out [ __ ] bacon
egg and cheeses all day bro open a
window do something get a fan going it's
either that or it's [ __ ] a vile
uh smell of cat litter which is a tough
those typically don't have grills those
typically don't have like the griddles
cooking yeah when you can smell the cat
litter
[Music]
not a fan
[Music]
anyway with patty to just put a button
on sure let's button it up
she went to do the dishes in the
dishwasher grab palm olive that'll ruin
the floor it was a
five i'm not lying i've done this it was
a five-day process yeah of her
constantly running the dishwasher get
the suds out then the guy had to come
out anyway guy from sears came out took
a look at it yeah wild i know it was a
lot i i caught my wife
did that
down ashore at the house uh we were out
of [ __ ]
uh what she not realized
they don't she i don't know she just
didn't know she was like oh it's soap
you know whatever
um treated me on top of that over there
in europe
yeah i don't know and i was just like
what are you doing i'm like you can't
it's not the same shoe i mean that was
one we did it back we had a babysitter
do it back in the 90s that's awesome and
she didn't know she was trying to be
like i'll clean up for i'll do the
dishes for when the parents get home
whatever
and i mean i remember i remember turning
we were in the family room watching a
movie and i walked out to like get ice
cream or something you know
something real sweet i wasn't to do chin
ups
it was to get my medicine ball
it's that
kettlebell i think it's in the paint
dude i turned the corner and
ah oh my dude it was like a sudden
monster coming
it was [ __ ] all over the floor it
wasn't she i was like yo tots we got an
issue out here
ma is gonna be pretty meh
and i'm like i did i was like i told my
mom yo i had nothing to do with this you
know i don't clean you know what is it
is this pre pizza or post pizza this is
late night this is like you know she ran
the dishwasher at nine they'll be home
at 10 or whatever
it was late using your dirt bag
tendencies to justify a not [ __ ] up is
amazing oh yeah you know i didn't do it
i'll touch that [ __ ] well it's also
like i just get blame i've always gotten
blamed for everything just sure i'm the
idiot the whatever
um
so i didn't even talk i guess i was
going to say this for our films but
whatever last whatever two weeks ago i
went down the shore right and i told you
i i talked about it on ayg i took dirty
clothes down in my mom's house to do and
i wasn't staying there i was staying
across the street
um
so i do the laundry
pick it up
that night take it back to the house
whatever
come over in the morning like 10 o'clock
whatever early 8 o'clock i walk over in
the morning
and there's a leak in the drive there's
a leak in the garage
my stepdad's got the ceiling opened up
there's water
and he's got to cut the drywall out yeah
to find the leak he doesn't know where
the leak is coming from so you got to
trace you got to cut you got to open up
the ceiling and trace the leak back i
know
so we're sitting up there and he's going
someone do laundry last night and i'm
like there's no way this was my [ __ ]
what cycled you put just trying to pin
this on me dude what's up yeah
what the [ __ ] man
dude am i i just you got to use gentle
i'm like i'll be the guy i broke i i
flooded the [ __ ] one this guy mr
[ __ ] permanent press over here yeah
blew out the pipes and half a wild one
he's going did you shower he and he was
just it was real it was real trying to
pin it all man i got my own place across
the street there's no washing dryer
also that's your fault if you can't
handle a [ __ ] super load you know
these pipes stink yeah dude you can't
[ __ ] be [ __ ] riding somebody for
now i literally was like dude this ain't
my fault you have a glass of water up
there yeah
who did you make ice or something like
that it was real who's brushing their
teeth i know i'm like sorry yeah and
i don't even know i i i i sounds like a
drain issue i massaged that real quick
but where it's kind of didn't make sense
where it was coming from huh
um
to piggyback onto that one this one's
from grandpa steve long time listen
never question red thanks cramps ever
evict a family member
which i gotta say i was closely almost
evicted by said stepdad
when
i was about 25. he had a he owned a
townhouse rental property sure convinced
him to let me
me and my knucklehead friend did right
we know the story yeah
i didn't know we tried to evict you
the lease wasn't up for renewal let's
put it that way were you late on
payments
there might have been like uh you know
on the sixth or seventh type thing sixth
or seventh waiting for you what do you
mean i'm just saying yeah
this guy doesn't play ball this guy
also he kept the security deposit i want
that out there wow yeah he kept the 1200
security deposit and i moved back
into his house
which was a awkward breakfast to say the
least wait why didn't he let you renew
the lease because he didn't want to deal
with it anymore yeah i think that was it
there's more to this story there's not
really come on
one i probably couldn't afford it
okay i mean if i'm paying if i'm paying
the rent payments late i couldn't afford
it dude two days is not late i
understand i'm telling you i know you're
poking for a deeper story there's not it
was just my roommate was moving out
did anyone is anyone playing along at
home catch what a dirtball foley is what
he said two days is not late meaning the
seventh because in his mind
this is the win the rent is due and this
is what the renters do
i'm on his side with that 100
this place is the 10th by the way i
remember somebody telling me that when i
was maybe like 19 or 18. it was like
discovering the fountain of youth
yeah it's got to be the fifth because of
the social security checks i had no idea
what a social security check was still
no i was not really yeah but i was a big
fan um love that back when back when i
was banging in my old apartment even
this one per this new one back before we
started making a couple of bucks i'm
still doing the fifth
i'm on autopay now
yeah it's pretty good i got everything
on all to pay but then what happens is i
lose that credit card i forget to re
put in my new one for all my stuff and
then it gets shut off my cell phone gets
shut off has gotten shut off on the past
two past two road dates we went on i got
back remember i got to the airport after
georgia or something yes i get to the
airport i'm trying to call an uber i'm
like this goddamn wi-fi just
i might go to make a call
we're redirecting you just written
payment
services yeah really send you right over
there it's freezing i got the credit
card i'm trying to put it in they left
me high and dry t-bone and tommy
they send you over there you're in
trouble oh yeah straight to the payment
center for you
and a little trick if you do get shut
down
you can still receive calls i think for
a little bit then they shut that down
after a day or so so get your pager out
get your page route
hey you got to restart your phone
and wait 15 minutes you don't just throw
it on airplane mode throw it off real
quick re-bust the system that would set
those jackets you've been rocking off
dude what clip a pager
yeah that'd be tight i had a pager
growing up no one ever paged me at not
once i was really upset my dad would
call i'd be at my friend liam's house
i'd be like hey dad page me when you
need me you know what i mean like page
me when you're coming i'll be ready
doing that [ __ ] no he called liam's
house and i'm like your dad's on the
phone what are you doing page me
somebody's pressing pounds not one page
never got one i don't even know the
number way my dad probably gave it to me
it wasn't even hooked up i was like yeah
yeah play with this one i only ever
paged one person coat dealer
it's pretty good
he didn't have a landline
uh
this one all right this is from eddie
lee uh first time brand new have you
ever rolled up a box like it's a bag of
chips to close it i.e a box of yolios
like yes you see what i'm like you curl
it up it took me a minute to understand
hold it in and then roll you like crunch
it yeah a box of uh eggos would do the
same yes that is a trash move yeah it's
trash it would be a flimsy box that
opens from the end typically a longer
skinnier box i learned toby still can't
wrap his head around that you'd need
coal miners hands to pull that move off
no it's thinned it's like [ __ ] it's
just somebody who maybe worked for a
living oh
not behind a keyboard all day it's like
construction important than doing ollies
it's like it's like laminated playing
wiffle ball whatever you and your
buddies are you don't even know what
goes on here
t-bone's
he's just got to show up and be funny
and he delivers
we're having a good time
um
you can do it but it's real trash oh
dude you open if i open up your freezer
and i see a curled up [ __ ] elio's box
i'm leaving i ain't i ain't sticking
around for breakfast what do you live in
whoville
[Laughter]
hooverville no no whoville because it's
[Applause]
um
i learned through many years of trial
and error how delicate
the situation is in the freezer
what do you mean you really got to take
care of your [ __ ] in the freezer because
that freezer burn ain't no joke no
and it really ruins [ __ ]
oh yeah [ __ ] up a pot sticker or a
pierogi before you can even [ __ ]
battle at it yeah so the rolling it
doesn't help it doesn't it might buy you
20 minutes or something it's not
the the freezer burns gonna get through
your roll you need hard plastic seal on
the food item and then you need th the
box
clothes nice yes
let's talk about butcher box baby love
that butcher box yes we do i got a i got
a freezer full of meat to prove it i'm
telling you that right now gang if you
like top quality meat delivered right to
your door we're talking grass fed we're
talking free range we're talking
wild-caught salmon pork chicken chops
steaks burgers the whole nine yards yep
you want to get yourself a nice little
subscription to the boys over there
butcher box i love that ground beef baby
the the old lady just made some fresh
meat the balls
i popped you some last night so good
every month butcher ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
your home free shipping in a continental
u.s baby i don't care if you're in texas
maine
oregon wherever any us that's 40 states
uh no antibiotics no added hormones each
box contains 8 to 14 pounds of meat
that's insane depending on the box you
choose that's enough for 24 individual
meals packed fresh shipped frozen for
convenience so you save time in your
next grocery store trip you can
customize your own box or go with one of
the ones they have already curated
either way you get exactly what you want
this is your chance to never have this
is insane chance to never shop for
ground beef again that's right butcher
box is giving new members free ground b
for life plus a 10 off coupon sign up at
butcherbox.com ayg get your two free
elbows of ground beef freaking every
order all on the arm uh for the life of
your membership plus a 10 off coupon log
going to butcherbox.com
ayg to clean this deal
yeah athletic greens athletic greens
athletic greens i'm talking about ag-1
don't look at me stupid i'll come over
there and tune you up cause i'm all
jacked up on that guy's all swole now
he's taking his ag-1 feel frisky leap
baby i started taking it cause i started
working out i needed something to help
me power through my workouts it's
unbelievable i bring my little shaker
with me i drink it throughout my workout
bartender
bench press
i'm taking ag-1 shaking not stirred you
know what i mean
the best stuff ever yeah it's a one-stop
shop it tastes good
gets my gut health going keeps me
feeling good all natural tastes great i
can't say enough about it i swear to god
i take it all the time it's like a soup
if you're if you're new it's like a
super [ __ ] multivitamin it's got
everything you need in the shea it's 75
high quality vitamins minerals whole
food source super foods probiotics and
adaptogens which i still haven't learned
what they are it helps the nervous
system immune system energy recovery
focus aging all those things that you
need to take care of it'll charge your
phone contains less than one gram of
sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals no
artificial anything still tastes good
look at that so get involved uh to make
it easy athletic creams is going to give
you a free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase i
took the vitamin d this morning because
we're going on a road gotta have an
immune system pumped up there you go uh
for the meet and greets all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com garbage
again that's
athleticgreens.com to take ownership
over your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance now
at a shop back to the show makes me
really want an elios right now though
when's the last time you had one
uh
probably pandemic i would say i had one
i didn't have i was doing the uh
signature selects from acme during the
pandemic that's right man crushing them
things i would [ __ ]
i would fill i would cook of the flint
to four cheese
italian sausage i know it cook that
do
three off the rip three slices off the
rip it was like cut into a four banger
three off the rip
i let one sit harden up a bit
start boozing
typically white
what was it white tail wine yellowtail
wine the purple label i think it was a
cab yellow tail on a redneck
start crushing that stuff about a half a
bottle of outlet half the big bottle
what glass are you using for the wine
coffee cup
um
call out my afternoon coffee
there's no shot it was a wine glass
uh
i think it was one of those
i guess it would be a white wine the
short little stubbers like the ones
without the stem on it a goblet a goblet
would be one of those they're close or
just a rocks glass but the goblets we
had down the shore are plastic so i
think i would use a rocks glass
my money was for sure on a triple h
commemorative cup from seven no no no no
it was a little rocks glass which i tend
to like drink in my wine and even when i
do get a wine at the house or whatever
i'll do a rockstar
i don't know how this is going to be
perceived and this is strictly my
opinion but i would get drunk and then
have a slice of that with the red wine
about three hours later
cooled down a little bit ice cold oh god
damn freak [ __ ] crust you could [ __ ]
bounce a quarter off of two
damn it not new shabbat
pay you bums off and go have a pizza
somewhere
um
those first couple months of the
pandemic the two months
was not too bad
it was all right okay i know that's
[ __ ] up mm-hmm but it was but it was
the world didn't we we were also
powering around a lot because everybody
was stuck at home we started podcasting
every day we'd do hard feelings at 10
o'clock every morning or nine o'clock
we'd have our [ __ ] morning coffee me
and you would zoom for about a half hour
make fun of the birds get some chuckles
going 500 grocery order in the fridge
then order out
[Laughter]
booze stock to the rafters
yeah i know it was a bad time bad time
for a lot of people bad time for a lot
of people we understand um
here's something you made me think of
when you when you asked about a cup
do you have a cup in your bathroom
do you have like a one of those cups to
rinse whatever you do with it no some
people put their toothbrushes in it we
have one for the toothbrushes you do a
holder for the toothbrush a holder or a
cup a cup but i think it's a bathroom
cup it's like a
it's like a rubber hard rubber
could you drink out of it sure
we don't because the bottom the inside's
probably a little
icky that smells that's a tough smell um
the old toothpaste we keep our
toothbrushes in there
yeah
i don't really brush i typically always
have a bottle of water so i'll
brush my teeth and then like i use the
wall i use i kind of use it as a spoon a
little bit i know i just
i don't like doing it i love that um
so i'll like i'll and then rinse that
way and then i hit it with a nice bowl
nice bottle of pole and spring or
something in the bathroom no i'll walk
out and okay rehydrate brushing my teeth
dries my mouth out heavy bike
it's like [ __ ] spackle in there or
something
i don't know what you want his nails
this kid
my tongue's
dry i didn't
all right are you done
yeah i'm done okay okay
uh
let's see here
go ahead
get ahead
um guy for maine is your middle name and
nickname my middle name is eddie instead
of edward dude that
stinks
that's bad dude what's your middle name
william
real oh you didn't know that you yeah hw
henry william foley ii we've gone over
this you're not the second i am the
second [ __ ] i'm named after my
grandfather hey this is a comedy podcast
dude what the [ __ ]
jesus christ dude i called your mom a
[ __ ] 20 minutes ago you get mad at you
you be in the second she had it coming
[Laughter]
god damn putting palm off in a
dishwasher patty what are you doing down
there you're killing me
jesus christ you just got real [ __ ]
bad
yes it is chicken that was like a cat
was like a fifth grade fight
i like to hang out i have her butt
snitcher
this guy's ratting out all the butts
you button arc
real berry dinger
shout out to the berry dinger shout out
to him um
minor league baseball team barry um what
i'm
asking a question on your birth
certificate hold on i'm asking a
question
can you be the second if it's not in
order yes
okay this is a fun this is a fun app
this is a fun line of questions
you would be a junior
like if you named hans kevin james ryan
he would be kevin junior
if you skip that it's the second i
called him hans okay that makes sense
but then hans had kids this is he was
human
okay or some type of half-dog half-human
hybrid
which i'm interested in what did you
[Laughter]
to be quiet what did your grandfather do
for a living he was a truck driver he
was a teamster oh yeah that legacy needs
to live on
i worked for friedman's express
holland uh-huh that's how he did it
it's great and to honor him you turned
yourself into a drop yeah
i'm gonna be the size of a mack truck to
live to so my grandfather's name lives
on
we're doing the next way into the
buckies yeah
do they have those at bucky's oh they
got everything damn monkeys really has
everything
they have a truck weighing
yeah let's get your weight there's a guy
sitting there guessing
pull right up pull right in uh you're
looking about 18 000 pounds
1805. no we didn't go to bucky's
um
yeah a middle name
a nickname as the middle name is a tough
lock i don't understand how that would
even happen what do you mean well your
parents would if they want to call you
eddie or your nickname's eddie
i understand that but you would think
that the notary or wherever the [ __ ] you
get your birthday to get what where do
you get that done sears what do you get
the notary who does birth certificate
the hospital
oh really see yeah
they print them out there yeah you don't
go to like the auto tag place
when you renew your [ __ ]
yeah that's crazy yeah they fill them
out those places always seem like a scam
to me any saturday i went with my dad oh
we were a big do something with the tags
that we were a big auto tags players we
still are bitching we're a big auto tags
family what do you mean
we get a lot of stuff done at the auto
tag place instead of going to the dmv
cause they're on their big thing is
we're online with the state i need a new
set of parking permits can you name my
kid
this is a junior i think
can you stamp his feet can you do the
ink
yeah they do it at the hospital okay so
you would take that weird to go to a
second location to get that done
you're at cvs getting your passport
photos and your kid name i don't i don't
know if yeah if you had to go to like uh
city hall or something like that
what do you think happened to the city
hall
uh night court
that's honestly what i think comes out
of that it's just night court and people
getting married uh you are a great a
bizarre
anyway you would think that the hospital
workers or the administrators or whoever
wouldn't allow you to do that you need
to you need a real name
yeah but these people are clearly
dirtbags i mean yeah sure eddie
yeah i love the name eddie that's a
tough one
that's tough this is another fun one
this is from jordan first time long time
uh is it garbage if i'm a if i'm 22 and
foley is older than my parents
yeah you're a dirtball yeah you're 22.
that means you're not your parents their
parents 23 22. yeah i think that's
exactly what
my parents were when they had me yeah
but times have changed i feel a lot sure
but you can still do it times have
changed in the regard of you can get
married and have kids later i don't
think there's any shame in
oh no not at all people still getting
you know people falling in love finding
the right person and getting married and
living their lives
didn't happen for me
better luck next year
uh all right this one's from taylor ever
install a rollout awning on your
house a roll-out awning uh-huh this is a
deep cut they used to promo these heavy
on like not infomercials but infomercial
type commercials
where it's like 600 bucks or 299.
they're one size fits all you get like
they can get a nine by nine if i can
12x12 a big whatever
it's real janky it was the same
commercial for about 20 years yes yeah
it's an old family
they just so it's really instead of like
building a deck or something
you just set up a couple of lawn chairs
and then just like roll out the awning
so you're in the shade imagine like the
side of a camper that was the um that
was the selling point was in the
backyard the boiling sun right
down on you yeah the dad the jerk off
was sitting out there all cooking
couldn't read his magazine and then he
has that thing and he's here yeah now
we're living
yeah i mean i get it they're good but i
do think it's i never thought about it
until this question and i just remember
seeing that commercial five thousand
times they were never put on the side of
like [ __ ] buckingham palace or
anything you know what i mean and if you
could put it on your house and also an
rv it's probably a tough look and i've
said this before and i know it's a
little snappy and refreshing
if
you you can't have all that [ __ ] outside
if you don't have a pool well what are
you doing you have one of those in just
some lawn chairs i just don't get it
there's got to be a pool
but what are you doing
what are you looking at you're just
sitting there looking at the grass
i kind of see what you're saying but
like yeah what i'm saying if you put the
awning out and the lawn chairs and this
and that something somebody i don't care
if it's a kiddie pool but i think you're
looking at like
august in philadelphia
when it's 100 degrees out if it's a nice
spring night or like you know not
everybody has the same climate so like
it might not get as hot or whatever but
like or even for those days where it's
like hey it's 78 sitting in the back
watching the [ __ ] whatever watching
the fireflies yeah something you know
as i get older sit back there a couple
of beers couple of buddies couple of
heaters call it a [ __ ] day yeah we're
living somewhere like massachusetts
where it's freezing most of the year and
you get like two hot stuff you're gonna
have a pool out there yeah i guess
you're right also not everybody's got
pool money i understand completely
mr olympic size in ground pool above
ground pool yeah we don't really have
pool money we got a leak in the pool too
right now
damn the place is going to [ __ ] down
here huh stuff look
it's like yellowstone
you need to hire a couple more hands
random i'll start working for you really
ramming with the hwf
i'll kill for you bury a couple of
bodies down by the creek
um
this one
all right so this is this is rare that i
do this this was a bit of a longer
question or so
but then also there was a response to it
because we have like a discussion thread
every week that we post and people a
discord
we do have a discord yeah um but this is
on patreon there's a discussion there
where people chime in blah blah blah
whatever i thought that was called a
discord
continue
um all right
my dad didn't know how to cook growing
up so when mom was gone we ate a piece
of bread topped with a layer of sugar
and then we poured milk over it he
cleverly called it milk bread felt
normal growing up but i've come to
understand this may in fact be garbage
let me know gentlemen and then someone
commented talk about starting from the
back of the pack
yeah man milk bread is a tough luck dude
a piece of bread let me see if i get
this recipe right it's just milk bread
and sugar on a plate or a bowl what are
you doing this in yeah i don't know how
that would work i'm assuming a deeper
plate and you would like like a salt
like and just
that's not even a meat like how do you
not figure out macaroni and cheese or
something some eggs or something
something milk bread is so crazy
yeah
you got bread peanut butter jelly toast
i'd rather toast over [ __ ] dude if my
dad or step dad tried to serve me milk
bread at one point i'd [ __ ]
emancipate myself
get the [ __ ] out of here take my chances
on the streets yeah dude
i know find me behind the dry cleaners i
know of an old world
eating hangers
um
i know of an old world stomach remedy
where you chop where you where you pull
apart white bread put it in a glass with
milk and eat it it coats the stomach and
like i think if you have like heartburn
or indigestion yeah milk of magnesia
type [ __ ] yeah um
it's a base that's got a function this
is just milk sugar and bread brown sugar
some cinnamon maybe i could see i don't
know
the craziest thing is the milk and the
bread is not the most bizarre concept to
me
i can see that
the show you can see a plate with a loaf
with a slice of white bread on it
with milk poured over it well i've just
i've started to pour milk on more things
or i was pouring milk on more things i
don't believe that either way like if i
have a piece of cake you put a piece of
cake in a bowl and fill it halfway with
milk what are we doing it's fine it's
awesome it's awesome yeah there's oh
yeah okay
i'm just for fat court i'm just saying
in my old ways
that's something that i would do so to
me that doesn't seem too crazy
the sugar but those things go together
a slice of chocolate cake and milk go
together i didn't say a slice of
chocolate whatever it was a slice of
bread and milk don't go together
you see what i'm saying that's not a
peanut butter and jelly cookies and milk
that's not the it's not the case wait
let me ask you this have you ever had a
peanut butter and jelly and dunked it in
your milk and taken a bite of it
sure okay
but that's the peanut butter and jelly
are leading the surge on that not the
white bread i understand
it's playing its part
sure but it's not the part it's that's
not playing the part
that's serving as a vehicle for the
peanut butter and [ __ ] jelly and milk
did you not say there was a response in
there or something like that
yeah he said start about talk about
starting from the back that was it okay
there was no more follow-up as far as no
i i'm i'm shocked that you're so thrown
by this would you want it to be savory
what
you're saying the sugar is you're jammed
up on the sugar would you want that i'm
just jammed up on the white sugar part
of it i could like i said i could see
some cinnamon
some brown sugar maybe
i'd have to know how it's constructed is
it in a bowl is there more than one
piece of bread how much sugar are you
putting who gives you first of all none
of this matters it is an absolute piece
of trash who gives their kids that for
dinner that's what hillbillies rednecks
those poor kids had to eat in the dark
while they were hiding from social
services too nuts too
everybody hit the deck
there's definitely been times when
that's happened i'm sure
tunnel lights out hit the deck duel
collector somebody's showing up
have we ever done that i think we've
done something like that but i think it
was more to avoid somebody we were a big
no phone call
i'm not here my dad was we've talked
about why that was never there yeah all
of the 90s you answer the front door
if someone knocks yeah yeah you scope
you fully peek out the window see what
kind of car we're looking at you know
are you expecting anybody who's that
yeah also my dad back i'm not here
usually the front door was the was the
screener somebody went to the front door
we knew they weren't company yeah it
wasn't it wasn't a friendly no
friendlies come around back to the team
i'm saying ours were coming through the
garage yeah or around back yeah
[ __ ] front door but that thing was
deadbolted shut yeah with boards going
across it
tough lizard yeah um this one's from zek
have you ever have you or anyone you
sorry have you or anyone you know ever
had a trampoline in your backyard for
more than four consecutive seasons
which i'm confused about
i think this guy insinuates
that you take it down
in the winter what that's crazy talk
crazy
and by seasons he means years
i think he means the summer season as
kevin has alluded to yeah i think he
means like
if you leave it up for four seasons this
had multiple likes on it too meaning
that like oh that's a good question hmm
i get is that a i mean we like we had
had one up for four years straight in
the backyard dude
can you take them down don't they get
set in place with the springs and stuff
you can just undo it i guess
i don't know
it doesn't make sense i mean
we never had a trampoline my sister's
got one of that thing's been up for
[ __ ] three four years yeah it just
stays up you go out there in the winter
i think you're a real hoity-toity if
you're breaking down and putting it back
up every spring that's wild
that's class
yeah that's pretty good
i mean who's got the room to store that
anyway i know
it's insane you're gonna park the snow
blower you know what i mean oh [ __ ] got
weed in here bro
um
adam h ever used your mouth to get a
good vacuum on a ziploc bag
never thought of it yeah then you got
what like tomato sauce in your lungs or
something they just
i think i even thought of that it's like
a vacuum sealer yeah i get that how do
you feel about those vacuum sealers we
dabbled in them for a minute oh yeah you
patty pushing weight
a little bit yeah like putting the
blankets away or whatever the [ __ ] oh
you're talking about the one you
actually attached the vacuum to
oh that's trash dude oh yeah sure we got
one trash really my wife moved here with
one or no she did she bought one or used
hers or bought the bags
to suck it out so because she had to
move all of her clothes here when she
moved they work great so it's [ __ ]
compressed like a whole wardrobe down to
like a [ __ ] size of a t-shirt
yeah it was about too bad it was about
18 000 pounds but still yeah those
things are all right madmar dude that
[ __ ] infomercial blew my mind they
would dip it in water pour ink on it
everything then cut it open and like oh
cashmere i was like ma we gotta get this
they also had it for for the kitchen we
have one of those as well
never worked
my stepped out would be like you could
marinate montreal chicken in here i'm
like no you can't
hit the [ __ ] scene like a goddamn
michael jackson song oh man [ __ ] hey
i never been to my it's that's no one's
still using that right the first time i
had it i was like what the [ __ ] is this
this has got everything
that's not fair
everything i've i've i remember the
first we were
my stepdad
was making chicken
it was like a fall night or something we
had to go pick my brother up grill
he was going to be grilling it yeah uh
and then
something happened where my brother was
supposed to get picked up from soccer
practice down in philly but he couldn't
so he got a call like from the other mom
hey we can't get him can you get the
kids or probably my aunt actually
because they were on the same team
my brother my aunt she was
shout out to pat shout out to him patty
hell of a keeper
there she was a big flopper and i
remember
so we had a it marinated for like the
two and a half out we had to drive down
get hit and came back
and dude um i remember i remember
cutting into this piece of chicken and
being like what in the [ __ ] is this dude
he's like that's montreal chicken i'm
like holy schnikey and then that was
great
but then they changed her he got like
buying off brands
or something well that was mccormick's
was the proper one okay proper labeled
montreal chicken then he started getting
you know trying to pinch pennies and go
in the gym
everything in that [ __ ] for about three
straight years yeah burgers steaks god
damn it that on a [ __ ] piece of steak
yeah trash olaf
um
[Music]
but the vacuum seal i respect the move
especially when it comes for the
greenery mm-hmm yeah i mean
um
keep my weed fresh
this one we this one's about that's my
smoke
smoking weed
um
smoking doobies you know i like an
edward norton every once in a while and
i see eddie
and edie falco oh nice edie falco
all right this one's from petey peppers
uh it's about radar detectors which
obviously we've talked about but this
one did you or did you have a radar
detector installed in your car i had one
that claimed they would pay my ticket
and guarantee it but it only went off
when i drove by supermarkets
that's great dude i mean i could picture
him figuring that out be like slopping
him like hey it's in front of the
[ __ ] jinnardi's every time what's
going on here
oh man man that's true
we're in a police scanner family we got
to do it uh we were cb my dad and i
stepped out of the cb in the ford ranger
man driving down the shore i was sitting
middle seat on that with my brother to
my right my stepdad crank and bernie's
man having fun on that cb radio [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah people get get off this
channel baker breaker suck my balls
break a break or suck my balls over
[Laughter]
it was a good time we had a guy come
looking for us one time that's what they
always say that's never they don't know
where the [ __ ] you are
they can't triangulate it what i don't
know
no
no
that's gonna save a radar detector
pick up your supermarket
um all right this one's from honey baked
rum ham oh i like that um filtered have
you ever filtered cheap vodka through a
bit brita pitcher multiple times to make
it better vodka
also then you have a nice cold pitcher
of vodka in the fridge i didn't know you
could do that i think it's
pretty genius that that dropped when we
were in college
you would buy the [ __ ] and you were
on a budget you would buy the pop-off
the what were the other ones
pop-off was the big one we would get it
was like you know of course nine bucks
for the the jug the handle wolferschmidt
or something like that i don't remember
that one there was a bunch pop off and
anything big in plastic bacon plastic
yeah at the bottom there was on the
bottom shelf you know what i mean
get one of those cooking vodka and the
girls
are you guys making penne
[Laughter]
the girls would run it through the brita
so they can make like [ __ ]
vodka tonics or whatever you know
because we were just ripping shooters it
didn't matter to us
pour that in the trash can chop up some
[ __ ] oranges and ice some kool-aid
packets and some [ __ ] lemon yeah
let's make some [ __ ] bad decisions
but yeah it's it's trash but at the same
time you gotta do what you gotta do
something pretty classy
that's trash trying to be clear it's not
classy that's not okay open up dude if i
went to someone's house and if i went to
a friend's house
today and i opened up their refrigerator
and they had a brita full of [ __ ]
cheap vodka
you'd be like what the [ __ ] are we doing
here you wouldn't be like yeah all right
it's pretty classy you like you have
[ __ ] problems you'd have a drink
though wouldn't you ah yeah we thought
we'd discuss it over a cocktail like
gentlemen
all right we gotta wrap it up gang we
[ __ ] love you we'll see you next week
come see us out on the road on a road on
the road yeah second show at it in
chicago second show out of chicago
denver utah phoenix gang come out and
see us at the live show yes we love you
and we'll see you next week
[Music]